El dióxido de carbono, o CO2,
es el gas principal de efecto invernadero.
¿Cómo entra el CO2 en nuestra atmósfera?
Bueno, el carbono es parte de un ciclo.
Empieza con el sol
que calienta la superficie terrestre
con más energía
en una hora que lo que el mundo usa en un año.
Las plantas, que son como chefs biológicos,
toman esa luz solar y luego absorben
algo de CO2 del aire,
los mezclan y ¡bam!
Crean una forma de energía almacenada
en forma de carbohidratos
como la glucosa y la sacarosa.
El proceso se llama fotosíntesis.
Cuando los animales como nosotros
comemos las plantas
nuestros estómagos convierten ese alimento
en energía para nuestro propio crecimiento.
Los gases de invernadero
son un subproducto de este proceso
y se liberan a través de los residuos.
Al morir esas plantas, se descomponen y microorganismos descomponen
los hidratos de carbono
y, nuevamente, liberan gases de invernadero
como subproducto.
La energía proviene del sol. Luego se transfiere al avanzar a través de la cadena alimentaria.
Pero a veces los organismos carboníferos, como plantas y animales, quedan atrapados en la tierra.
Cuando esto ocurre, se comprimen
bajo toneladas de presión,
y se convierten en combustibles fósiles carboníferos
como el petróleo, el carbón y el gas natural.
Desde la Revolución Industrial, los humanos
hemos extraído combustibles fósiles de la tierra
y quemado, activando la energía almacenada
para producir electricidad y motores.
Pero eso también libera al aire millones
de años de CO2 almacenados.
Además, los seres humanos respiramos
oxígeno y exhalamos CO2.
Pero las plantas hacen lo opuesto.
Los árboles absorben grandes cantidades de CO2,
lo que equilibra el ciclo.
Así, la deforestación reduce
las plantas que almacenan CO2.
Estamos atacando el ciclo por dos lados.
Piénsenlo como una computadora que puede
ejecutar pocos programas al mismo tiempo, ¿sí?
Por lo general, al terminar un documento,
lo grabamos, y lo cerramos,
a fin de no sobrecargar a la computadora.
Imaginemos que dejan de cerrar los documentos.
Y que quedan todos abiertos a la vez.
La computadora no podrá procesarlos.
Se volvería más lenta, hasta congelarse,
y con el tiempo estallaría.
Eso podría pasarle a nuestro ambiente
si seguimos sobrecargando el ciclo del carbono.
¿Hay alguna forma de reequilibrar el ecosistema?
¿Y la tecnología? La tecnología se define
como una técnica que resuelve un problema.
Las tecnologías sustentables son aquellas
cuya salida es igual a su entrada.
No crean externalidades negativas,
como CO2, ni en el presente ni en el futuro.
Es como que se autocancelan al
resolver el problema.
Para lograrlo, tenemos que inventar
tecnologías sustentables.
Si ponemos todas las ideas y tecnologías
de la historia en un círculo,
la invención sería la expansión
de los límites de ese círculo.
El área exterior al círculo es infinita,
es decir, el potencial de invención no tiene límites.
Piensen en tecnologías limpias increíbles que tenemos hoy:
Eólica; autos eléctricos y solar, biogas.
Biocombustibles, algas fotosintéticas, compost...
Todas estas tienen algo en común.
Todos proceden de personas.
Las personas innovan.
Las personas crean. Es el potencial ilimitado
de las personas creativas
el que creará tecnologías inimaginables
que detendrá el cambio climático
para reequilibrar el ecosistema.
Y eso es algo esperanzador.